it's been one week since i dove deep
into the brand new galaxy fold 4 and its
accessories testing out samsung's
ecosystem after being stuck in apples
for many years so here are my honest
thoughts and opinions now last year with
a full three i was really disappointed
and fairly harsh in my review so do i
still hate samsung's foldables or have
things changed well honestly i really
only have a few complaints so let's dive
in the design of the fold is fantastic
the quality is top notch the hinge is
much improved and the seam that is still
here isn't noticeable day to day it's
weird saying that something actually
feels higher quality than my 13 pro but
it does it is very solid now on this
side right here with this front screen
this is one area that i complained about
last year this has been much improved we
have a full size screen here it is
really bright and it could go all the
way down to one hertz which saves a lot
of battery that's gonna be important in
a second as far as usability i really
like how narrow the phone is and it's
very comfortable to hold in the hand
even though it is thick and then when
you open it up compared to last year way
more apps are optimized and work
properly whereas before someone even go
full screen i absolutely love the bar
here at the bottom so you can quickly
switch to a different application the
first time i used it was actually
completely by accident and then it hit
me wow i literally just did that
naturally and it's so quick for the apps
that you use often overall the whole
phone is extremely fast with that
updated snapdragon processor now of
course on the cpu not much has changed
but as far as graphics it has gotten
much better and playing games on the
fold 4 is amazing with this large screen
there's no slowdowns heat is not an
issue it's a great experience but for my
favorite game which is call of duty and
probably others like it it actually
isn't great
not because the visuals aren't good it's
because of the aspect ratio certain
things on the sides get cut out and
there'd be people opponents that i
straight up would not see compared to a
regular wide phone now as for regular
use i want to talk briefly about the new
watch i think this is the first android
watch in a long time that is actually
good performance is great i like the
look of it the only issue is that it's
kind of thick and i don't love the
controls that it's all touch screen and
then that we have these buttons we don't
have that dial anymore but the battery
life is ridiculous you can go two full
days and you still have some extra power
compared to my apple watch which only
does about one day and then if you're
using things like maps uh or you're
doing a lot of active tracking for
workouts it could be half a day and it's
gone so i think android other than the
design the watches are finally at a
point where they do work well and if
you're using a samsung phone and you
want a smart watch don't hesitate i
think you'll enjoy it now there's a
couple more things that really surprised
me about the fold the first are the
speakers they were pretty good last year
but this year they are amazing beats my
iphone and the pro max version in every
single way loudness bass samsung has
done a really good job so if you're
watching videos if you're listening to
music
the experience is wonderful and of
course you can cup them that way the
sound actually bounces off your hands
right into your ears instead of being
front facing and both speakers are the
same and with that the video quality as
well now this is a large screen and
square so yes if you zoom in some stuff
gets cut out but even without zooming in
the the size of the video is still
bigger than the 13 pro max the hdr also
looks better it is brighter more
contrast the visual experience is
fantastic
now with that i want to bring in these
headphones as well
these buds 2 pro are amazing i've been
using airpods pro ever since they came
out and each time samsung releases new
earbuds they keep getting better and
these now are better than the airpods
pro in almost every single way the sound
quality amazing microphones have been
much improved noise cancellation is
better i was flying uh with them and i
actually didn't use my airpods max i was
just using these um comfort is really
good i think up to three hours that's
really the only downside where after
about three hours i start getting some
pain around where they touch my ear
but other than that i mean samsung is
really killing it and no samsung did not
provide any of these products for us to
review we bought all of them so earbuds
fantastic now of course if you're using
with your iphone you don't have all the
extra features that i love so that is a
downside there but getting back to the
fold i want to talk about the cameras
because last year they were not good
this year though we have had a huge
upgrade and in our blind camera
comparison
the fold 4 actually beat out the s22
ultra updated and the iphone as well
uh it doesn't have that telephoto shot
so sometimes it did worse but overall
the images look great the portrait shots
are amazing
even the inside camera even though i
typically wouldn't use it it's gotten a
lot better and i've been using it to
have to use face unlock it works fast
every time very consistent so there's no
longer a compromise spending way more
money but getting worse cameras because
they were great and i think the 50
megapixel camera it actually does better
for processing because it's a lot less
pixels and then with it for video the
video actually looks pretty good as well
because with the s22 ultra i mean you're
just throwing away so much data where
this one it looks good now the only
thing i would say is that sometimes it's
a little too over saturated a little bit
over sharpened as far as the video but
samsung's definitely come a long way
still not the level of the video on the
iphone that's definitely a head
but they are heading in the right
direction and the last thing that
surprised me was the battery life the
battery is larger in here there's a lot
more optimizations better processor the
screens go lower as far as the frequency
and you get eight to nine hours of mid
to heavy use and that's very surprising
so it's no longer a downgrade and then
with that
the one thing that i kind of found is
that after about three days or so i
ended up using the front screen way more
often because it's way more usable now
so i would say towards the end of that
week i was using probably 80 the front
screen and then really opening it up
when i needed that larger display and at
that point the battery life got even
better and that's when i started kind of
questioning do i really need a foldable
phone if only twenty percent of time i'm
using this screen here and i'm
preferring the normal phone like i have
in years past kind of the novelty
started to wear off
and with that the s pen didn't get that
much use now one reason is just because
it there's no spot for it you know you
have that extra case that samsung has
that makes it a lot more bulky it
doesn't feel great in your pocket and a
few times i just left it here and then i
went on a trip and i also left it as
well i think if there's one thing that
could make this better it would just be
to have the s pen built in even if that
means a little bit worse battery life uh
if they have to you know make some space
for that pen it would just take it up
just another level to have it with you
at all times and with that we have of
course the price people expected
foldable phones to come down in price
after they've been out a couple years
but they haven't this thing's still very
expensive now samsung does give you
sales they'll give you some accessories
uh they'll give you a larger storage
capacity if you pre-ordered but that's
not the same as dropping this thing down
to say fifteen hundred dollars maybe
fourteen hundred now will they ever do
it i'm not sure but at this point it is
just such an expensive phone for people
to buy now me personally i don't think i
need this i feel like at that price
point and the fact that after a week i'm
mostly using the front screen i'd rather
just have an ipad in my bag for those
times where i do want the full display
and then when i don't have a much
smaller regular phone um but with that
said they've done a lot of little
innovations they've changed a lot of
things compared to the previous one
software is catching up but i think this
year is the first year where it is a lot
more viable for a lot of people and then
with that when you factor in what
they've done for their earbuds way
better than apples at this point
with the
watch also a lot more improved killer
battery life it's an ecosystem that does
really well and you're not as tied in
now compared to apple of course uh the
imessage thing you know some people will
send you a message and you won't get it
because they're sending it to your email
uh or group messages suck i mean those
are the kind of things that hold you
back or if you're used to icloud sharing
for photos uh ear tags is a big one for
me i'm using a lot of ear tags now
that's where it's also harder to move
over but you guys let me know your
thoughts are you happy with the fold
four
i think it's been a much bigger
improvement than i expected and overall
it is a great device if only they could
fix those couple issues that i still
think they need to address thank you
guys for watching go ahead and click
that circle above if you guys want to
see more videos like this one check out
those blind camera comparisons if you
haven't seen them they're super fun this
one max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]